hey man how are ya good are you doing
good
wow if Neelam's your spirit at all then
you're she's a beast she is a beast
hey don't good how's work great good
tell me people murmur the best very very
happy with ya you ended up with an 18
yeah that's just a way that's the truth
yeah first other colors it worked out
yeah and so what what are you working on
right now yep I'm what brands
I'm also hip goes I just do like
management hip but I'm doing it I love
you
that's nice part about them is since
they're so solid they let me do up
things yep and across the board all of
them like they're outperforming higher
so they let the person under than 100%
smart about it that's why it's like you
know how we know each other's like it's
a sports analogy you're gonna get
drowned by great team yeah it's good
it's good to get lucky sometimes and
what about the macro culture of the
company outside of your day to day
that's a good point yeah I mean she was
a human sport no it's great and I would
say like movie like coming into this as
you've seen my expectations but little
you know compared to what I mean yeah
and the basketball stuff has been grew
huge yeah it's been great it's great
yeah
eliminates yeah people that want to be
there yeah for sure
what can I answer for you question
building communities advice between what
is that day right go ahead I'm listening
content outside like blogs SEO versus
just social for the purpose of a
start-up that is just trying to be in a
volume cool so is this like for like
your side house self rent your friends
yeah you guys what do you can you meet
guys like Brandon got us John Henry yep
what is it his just his personal friend
who's Brandon's yet the kid we played
with it what's he do it's awesome
um you're gonna get more bang for your
buck I mean you're gonna get there's so
much so
what's good about search and blogs is
there's like far more guaranteed singles
and doubles what's great about social is
there's so many more potential for
homeruns and Grand Slams and so it just
depends on how you want to play it it
comes down to economics a lot of times
so and menswear is going to over-index
visually so that's where Facebook and
Instagram things of that nature visitor
yeah I mean look look search is real
like real people meaning yeah I mean
search is the great intent marketing
vehicle of our time I have a weird rash
you know how to solve this bike problem
so so what search is incredible for is I
have a specific thing I want to scratch
right now and I'm gonna go to this site
Google and I'm gonna find something
what's great about social is you're
interested in basketball and it comes to
you it's passive versus going on the
offense and what's great about social is
it's got built-in word-of-mouth so you
are an individual trying to solve your
fashion problem in a menswear thing
you're never gonna tell anybody about
what you're doing there's no inherent
word-of-mouth brand building whereas in
social if what you discover that I'm
interested in that I see it the
amplification percentages are very high
even built in Instagram you DoubleTap
something your friends look at what
you're liking so it's just a very very
very very different insular versus
outward thing for me that's why socials
been so big for small brands they don't
have they don't have anything yet and so
they rely so much on word-of-mouth
strong
yes yes yeah I mean I think the variable
of the subject matter what the person's
bringing to the table if if this is a
menswear a product that has 89 percent
of its overall macro energy in Brandon's
heart and brain is to sell this product
if that's 89 percent he's gonna have an
11 percent community the reason I have
such a big community is I'm the reverse
that's what people don't understand like
it's playing a marathon versus a sprint
when you don't have the luxury like
Brandon probably doesn't of like waiting
two years to monetize whatever he's
doing you go in for the sale and what
happens when you go in for the sale is
the people on the other side of it feel
it it's a value exchange game that's
exactly right and I sit here on a
pedestal because I've been able to put
in the work for 20 years and I have the
leverage now to do that but day one it's
hard you know day one 22 year old Gary
trying to sell wine I don't know if I
would have had of 97 percent you 3
percent me strategy as a matter of fact
I know I didn't it was more 50/50 but I
even then knew it wasn't 98 to and
that's what most people do why you
producing content because you really
want to sell your [ __ ] if you want to
sell your [ __ ] in the short term your
content and your energy deploys that
behavior if you think about I'm gonna
try to stay alive for two years and the
content I'm gonna put out is just gonna
build relationship and then I'll be able
to monetize that some way in two years
your content looks very different all of
a sudden you're in there answering
people's fashion questions you're just
thinking about it differently see where
I'm going yeah it's my big question 22
year old advice New York in the digital
games
I mean it comes down to your ambition I
think the answer is far more like what
do you want to happen in life and then
how do you want to get there so you know
the serendipity of being at this I mean
if you're in a digital game you stepped
into [ __ ] because you stepped into the
best place at a time when a lot of
people didn't realize that that was the
case which means you have
disproportionate value you know
everybody's gonna want to work here now
but they're gonna come in at a different
company like like you have a lot of
value and you came in as employee number
five or who the hell knows what number
you came in right well guess what the
people that came in at number thirty and
forty have been more value right so I
think it comes down to like you want to
have your own agency do you want to have
you know like it's amazing and I'll give
you a really good piece of ice it's been
interesting to watch 22 year olds that
have asked me that question who tell me
they want to have their own shop and I
would say I'll help you you'll learn so
much here I'll be an I'll be a external
mentor we'll get to know each other you
work here for five to seven years and
give me a lot of blood sweat and tears
I'll even help even more financially
relationships it's been interesting to
see how many of those 22 year olds are
now 26 and now say to me I don't want my
own shop I found love I like my
work-life balance here I believe in you
I like the idea of making $200,000 a
year and having that life other people
went the other way I think I don't know
I'm gonna work at Boehner my whole life
and make a hundred thousand and now
they're like wait a minute
maybe I can have my own like so I think
the one thing to understand is 22 year
old Jacob and 27 year old Jake of a 33
year old Jacob are very different dudes
I wouldn't [ __ ] yourself with you
know don't let your ambition create and
whatever your mission whether most
extreme I want to buy the Jets or
whatever it may be
don't let it be in permanent marker guys
and I think the other thing is
relationships matter that's life and so
the thing we started this meeting with I
would highly recommend spending 30
minutes in the cafeteria every day and
working and saying hello
it's just insane that there's that Chris
right there that is the guy that might
create an opportunity for you and like
how many people will not even say hello
yeah so I'd be more social professional
yeah there's so much value here this I
mean the one greatest thing I've created
here is that it's easy to say hello to
somebody here that's what your friends
are telling you that they work in a
place where you can't [ __ ] say hello
to anybody is that's not allowed
that's the horseshit out there that's
the best thing here so then do it it's
really real and it creates different
opera
like always to work here for 37 years
even internally they'll create
opportunities
yeah go ahead one yeah he got a new job
now but he's trying to leave living
brother stuff like individual sports
whatever and yet my sporty direction you
should go again you know whether it's 22
years and it comes down to like how does
he want to work for 13 more years 8 3
where is he financially like that like
it's so hard it's why you have to know
those things but I you know I would give
my you know listen I've come to really
like you if you two come in jam with me
for 15 minutes 20 minutes I'd be willing
to do that I have a lot of relationships
you know I'd be more than happy to help
him but I need to know what the [ __ ]
cares about like if he's like dude I
just want to go for 3 more and go home
good so if he's in the game then I think
then I think it comes down to a
financial thing of what can he afford
does he want to be executive so kid were
recruiting right now his dad took a huge
pay cut as an Operations SVP to be the
first SVP operations he was right and so
he left you know half his salary on the
table because he could afford to and
that stock turned into the greatest nest
egg of all time became rich let alone
successful so I think go through that
too he needs to decide if he's gonna go
for eight to 15 more can he afford to
make 80 thousand at bleacher report
versus 235 at NBC Sports got it that's
how he has to think about it that's the
black and white decision and then if he
can afford it then I would push him very
heavy to more fun more autonomy more
upside better energy and if he can't
then you got a look at the alternative
and trying to find the best version of
that in that corporate environment yep
cool see ya talk to you soon
you too